god is dead god remains dead and we have
killed him friedrich nietzsche wrote in 1882
to understand what the german philosopher meant
and what he thought of men morality and society
as a whole we collaborated with professor
stephen hicks on this sprout special series
part one god is dead for thousands
of years humans have been religious
but in the modern world religion has
become a shadow of its former self
nietzsche's dramatic phrase god is dead is meant
to capture the shocking quality of this revelation
for those raised religiously
religion personalized the world
it gave them a sense that the world had a
purpose and that they were part of a larger plan
it gave them the comfort that despite appearances
we are all equal and cared for and that upon death
instead of a cold grave a possible
happily ever after ending awaits
but in the modern world we find it increasingly
hard to believe those values we have seen the
dramatic rise of science which has offered
less comfortable answers to questions religion
traditionally had a monopoly on we have thrown off
the shackles of feudalism with its unquestioning
acceptance of authority and have become more
individualistic and naturalistic in our thinking
but in historical time all of this has happened
very quickly for millennia we have been religious
but come the 19th century even the average
man had heard that religion may have reached
the end of its journey for most of us even
the suggestion of this hints at a crisis
imagine a 13 year old who is awakened in the
middle of the night to be told by strangers
that both his parents have died he is suddenly an
orphan for as long as he can remember his mother
and father were present in his life looking after
him and guiding him now they are gone and ready or
not he is thrust into that world alone how does
the young teen handle that sudden transition
culturally nietzsche says we are like that young
teen for as long as we can remember our society
has relied upon god the father to look
after us but now suddenly we are orphaned
we wake up one morning to discover that in
our heart of hearts our naively childhood
religious beliefs have withered so now
whether we like it or not a question
creeps into our minds how do we face the
prospect of a world without god and religion
in the 19th century says nietzsche most
people did not face that question well
most people avoid the issue sensing that even to
raise it would be to enter dangerous territory
life without religion is too scary to contemplate
so they retreat to a safety zone of belief
and repeat nervously the formulas
they have learned about faith
slightly better to nietzsche but not much
are the socialists of the 19th century
socialism is on the rise and many socialists
accept that god is dead but then they are very
concerned that the state take god's place and look
after them the mighty state will provide for us
and tell us what to do against the mean people of
the world think of it this way the judeo-christian
tradition says this is a world of sin in
which the weak suffer at the hands of the
strong that we should all be selfless and serve
god and others especially the sick and helpless
and that in a future ideal world heaven
the lion will lie down with lamb and the
inescapable power of god will bring salvation
to the meek and judgment to the wicked
the socialist tradition says this is a world
of evil exploitation in which the strong take
advantage of the weak but we should all be
selfless and sacrifice for the good of others
especially the needy from each according to
his ability to each according to his need
and the forces of history will necessarily
bring about a future ideal world that will
end all harsh competition empowering the
oppressed and eliminating the evil exploiters
both religion and socialism thus glorify weakness
and need both recoil from the world as it is
tough unequal harsh both flee to an
imaginary future realm where they can feel
safe both say be a nice boy be a good little
girl share feel sorry for the little people
and both desperately seek someone to look
after them whether it be god or the state
so where asks nature are the men of courage
who is willing to stare into the abyss who
can stand alone on the icy mountain top who
can look at tiger in the eye without flinching
to be continued
nietzsche who was born in 1884
was not only a fierce critic of
church and socialism but also nationalism
and anti-semitism his strong moral stance
meant that he openly condemned
many of his intellectual friends
and even broke his relationship with his own
sister who married a notorious anti-semite
so what are your thoughts on nietzsche do you
agree with his understanding of the world we
live in for more information
about this extraordinary man
and his impact on our society
check the descriptions below
there you'll also find a link to stephen
hicks full account of the german philosopher
this and all other sprouts videos are licensed
under creative commons that means teachers
from all around the world can use them in
classrooms online courses or to start projects
and today thousands already do to learn how it
works and download this video without ads or
background music check out our website or
read the description below if you want to
support our mission and help change education
visit our patreon that's patreon.com sprouts